[Musica]
salve a tutti i gentili telespettatori e
bentornati su discovery favi oggi
porteremo di rabbia umana quale sarebbe
la reazione dell'essere umano se
scoprisse di aver perso tutti i
salvataggi in un videogioco impossibile
scopriamolo oggi quello che state
guardando è un fa vj ignaro della
situazione che sta per accadere il
nostro ignare eroe si appresta a premere
invio
e a selezionare i salvataggi ma qualcosa
non va si accorge che il salvataggio
giusto non c'è e quale sarà la sua
reazione è da tutti i ragazzi e
benvenute questo nuovo video sono qua dj
ed oggi siamo tornati purtroppo ai
ragazzi ve lo dico ve lo dico molto
sinceramente io sto gioco non volevo più
farlo non volevo più ogni già detto è
costretto perché voi continuate a
chiederlo di continuo quindi raga sono
obbligato praticamente a farlo perché lo
sto fatto sto gioco perché prendiamo
inter ragazzi avevo un abile gaia il
diverso dagli altri leggi che non è che
tu lo fai
e poi non ci riesci a t'incazzi la prima
è diverso perché tipo che mario ad
esempio è un gioco a livelli cioè nel
senso tu passi un livello e poi ripartì
sempre da lì invece qua per gli eventi i
ribelli sono lunghissimi cioè prima
incapace che in un episodio sto sempre
nello stesso punto
e quindi è un po un casino più per un
attimo donna perché facilmente e si sta
parte è inguardabile cazzo praticamente
da un check point all'altro ragazzi
passa troppo c'è nel senso ci vuole
veramente troppo quindi per questo avevo
deciso di interromperlo donna non è che
posso stare tutto il video nello stesso
punto cazzo non lo so tipo in cat mario
celano i check point ma non c'è un cazzo
di niente se ci metti un ora arriva a un
check point fuga già fatta ragazzi ci ho
fatto non so come ok cazzo no ragazzi
giusto non ci posso credere non ci posso
veramente mancava una minchia avete
capito perché volevo decidere di
smettere di farlo avete capito perché
avete capito ci posso fare
ok ok ok ok ma non è possibile ma
[ __ ] ragazzi pagherei oro per
vedere il contatore delle morti su sto
cazzo di gioco impossibile voglio vedere
quanto sono arrivato gli incazzarmi 20
sono arrivato ma rivista che come cazzo
sono morto adesso non lo so gli hack
agati in testa un picciolo cosa pagano
ne posso io veramente voglio votare per
far chiudere gli scaricamenti a sto
gioco
si ok ok ok
ma se morisse muoia adesso son cazzi
suoi
[Musica]
sì sì no no no ho fatto altro che
cos'era cosa mi ha ucciso cosa ragazzi
mi sono schiantato contro una stella
ditemi se è normale i temi cioè normale
non aveva neanche vista con la merda di
stella ma io che cosa ne so sud
mi sto facendo malissimo al braccio ma
non me ne frega un cazzo
ragazzi non ci posso credere come fatto
c'è già c'è il checkpoint c'è il [ __ ]
checkpoint ce la posso fare
ragazzi devo farlo in questa cazzo di
vita perché non so come tornarci non ne
ho idea
[Musica]
ragazzi non si può fare sta roba
io non volevo neanche continuarlo merda
io lo sapevo che era cucita quello col
non voto
avevo detto no al colesterolo e si a sto
cazzo ragazzi si può fare questa roba
non lo studio perché ho continuato
perché ho detto va bene facciamo un
altro tentativo perché perché l'ho fatto
perché il ragazzo cat mari in confronto
è come giocare a barbie l'app è stronzo
loco ma [ __ ] tue da barbie e ken
gioverebbe ramente ragazzi vi giuro non
ho mai no non ho mai giocato una poi non
ho mai giocato
non ho mai giocato una cosa del genere
mai non ho mai giocato a un gioco che ti
facesse uscire così non si può lo si può
fare non si può finire ghazi non ho io
non so veramente come faccio a finirla
sta roba non ho idea cioè di giurata
ok ok ok adesso come cazzano molto prima
a sony ci sono o no o poi ragazzi mi sto
pagando addosso a pedate che ciò paura
ok ok ok
fai così no
non si può essere più [ __ ] delle
donne anche sono pochi già circolano i
dritti e gioca giochi stupidi perché me
lo chiedono i miei scritti ragazzino già
farò mai a fare sta parte non ce la farò
mai non ci ferma in japan ormai già sto
facendo sì ce l'ho fatta bravissimo hai
una vita incredibile
salta il primo ostacolo già fatta ma
come cazzo sta andando avanti non lo so
siamo arrivati al punto impossibile nel
quale morì royce clero come un pazzo ma
so che lo farò lo stesso indice posso
fare ce la posso fare
ce la posso fare no ci voglio crederlo
ma qualcuno no no no no no va giù ma giù
ragazzi ultimo tentativo lo faccio e poi
basta mi sono veramente rotto le palle
sono ore che sto prova ragazzi ultimo
tentativo poi giuro basta mi sono rotto
veramente i [ __ ] non è possibile
ok e fin qui ci riesco
[Musica]
luca ero di merda stiate schiantarvi
nelle foreste più sperdute le monde
sopravvivere ed essere divorati da un
fenicotteri noce ronte e che ve lo
infili amabilmente su per il cu ragazzi
misura è la prima volta che io mi
arrendo
mi arrendo definitivamente ad un
videogame perché non ci riesco
impossibile con pier mario era un'altra
cosa perché l'incasso saranno i
checkpoint almeno se morivi potevi
ritrovare ai 2 miliardi di volte lo
stesso pezzo non l'intero livello cazzo
impossibile ragazzi io vi giuro non
sapevo che alla finire così la per
questo che non lo continuava ma l'ho
fatto lo stesso ho voluto provarci ma vi
giuro ragazzi la prima volta che mi
arrendo perché no lì c'è la faccia anche
ragazzi seguito è piaciuto al di là
della merda il gioco lasciate al coperto
mi piace si lascia tempo sperando
lasciato mi piace non mi ricordo più
come visco i video e video è piaciuto
come al solito lasciato sgomento mi
piace anche la poesia di facebook e come
non imita trote nella descrizione
assenze reperisca gli scriventi avete ci
rivediamo il prossimo fino ai ragazzi
[Musica]